it's hard to get to space
as much as we all wish there were an
easy and affordable way to see our
planet floating in the dark
right now the only way is to become an
astronaut or a billionaire
but there is a concept that might make
it possible while serving as the
starting point for the exploration of
the universe the space elevator
how exactly does it work
[Music]
to understand how a space elevator will
get us into space we must first
understand what an orbit is
being in orbit basically means falling
towards something but moving fast enough
to miss
if you throw a ball on earth it makes an
arc through the air and then hits the
ground
in space gravity makes you move much the
same way but if you move sideways fast
enough the curvature of the earth makes
the ground fall away beneath you as fast
as gravity pulls you towards it
so to enter earth's orbit rockets have
to go up and sideways fast
by contrast a space elevator taps into
energy from the earth's rotation to get
the cargo going fast
imagine a child spinning a toy on a rope
with an ant on the child's hand
as the ant climbs out along the rope it
starts to move faster and faster as it
ascends
compared to rockets with cargo launched
on an elevator you only need to provide
the energy to go up fast sideways
movement comes free with the earth's
rotation
but a space elevator would without a
doubt be the single largest and most
expensive structure ever built by humans
so is it worth it
it all comes down to costs
rockets burn a huge amount of rocket
fuel just to get a small amount of cargo
into space at current prices it costs
about twenty thousand dollars to put one
kilogram of payload into space
that's one point three million dollars
for the average human forty million
dollars for your car
billions for an international space
station
this immense cost is one of the major
limitations of human space flight even
with advancing technology this cost
isn't likely to be comparable with the
price of an airline ticket anytime soon
a space elevator would solve this
problem after construction a space
elevator is projected to reduce the cost
100 fold to 200 per kilogram
if an inexpensive space elevator costs
20 billion dollars then we'll recoup our
losses after launching only 1 000 tons
close to the weight of two international
space stations so what would a space
elevator look like in real life
a space elevator has four major
components
the tether anchor counterweight and
climber the elevator part of the space
elevator is the tether and the climber
it extends from the surface of the earth
to space
the climber is like a conventional
elevator carriage a chamber that works
its way up and down the tether at the
base would be an anchor pinning the
tether to the earth along with a port
for climbers at the top is the
counterweight which holds up the tether
the tether is held tight like a rope and
supported from above by the tension from
the counterweight located higher than 36
000 kilometers above the earth's surface
at the counterweight could be a space
station a launching point for all
missions from the spaceport elevator
but can we actually build one it's hard
to say
the biggest challenge is the tether it
needs to be light affordable and more
stable than any material we can produce
right now
there are promising materials like
graphene and diamond nano threads but
even they may not be strong enough
and aside from being incredibly strong
the tether would also have to withstand
atmospheric corrosion radiation and
micrometeorite and debris impacts
additionally it takes several days to
climb the elevator
how do we power the climber
it requires a lot of energy to go up
do we need a nuclear reactor on our
elevator carriage
or do we beam it power from the ground
with a super powered laser and where do
we get the raw materials for a 36 000
kilometer long tether do we make it on
earth and launch it into space or do we
make it in space and lower it down to
the earth
could asteroid mining be the answer
put simply there are still some major
technological hurdles to overcome
and a space elevator is not without risk
should the tether break it would
collapse in spectacular style if it
breaks near the anchor the force exerted
by the counterweight will cause the
entire elevator to rise up ascending
into space
should it break near the counterweight
the tether will fall wrapping around the
world and whipping the end off the
resulting debris in orbit could pose
serious problems to future space flight
if we build a space elevator on earth we
have to do it right the first time
for these reasons some experts have
proposed first building a space elevator
on the moon the moon's gravity is much
weaker than the earth's so a flimsier
but existent material like kevlar could
serve as a tether
even with all these challenges the
payoff of having a working space
elevator would be immense it might be
the first step to truly becoming a
space-faring civilization
maybe we will never build a space
elevator but in trying to do so we might
learn an awful lot
and when it comes to the exploration of
the universe there can't be too many
dreams of a glorious future